[Música]
díaz gonzález cinco años doble arco
aórtico una enfermedad congénita de su
corazón
acá hay un frío tres años tráquea o
bronco malasia una enfermedad que
obstruya su tráquea y no le permite
respirar
text earl clark dos años nació con un
defecto en su hígado y necesita un
trasplante
bentley other seis meses encefalocele
parte de su cerebro está fuera de su
cráneo
qué tienen en común estos cuatro niños
además de tener una enfermedad
catastrófica grave compleja
difícil de diagnosticar
y difícil de curar
lo que estos niños tienen en común es la
impresión 3d
y el día de hoy les voy a explicar por
qué
pero antes quiero parar dos porque no
quiero que piensen que hoy voy a
hablarles acerca de impresión 3d o
impresión 3d de órganos o esas cosas del
futuro
a pesar de que estamos trabajando en
ello hoy no quiero hablar de eso
hoy quiero concentrarme en un aspecto de
la impresión 3d que la hace tan crucial
en medicina y es la personalización
pero antes de eso quisiera poner los
puntos sobre las íes y responder quizás
la pregunta que algunos ustedes tienen
hoy
qué es la impresión 3d
la impresión 3d es básicamente utilizar
datos de un dibujo en tres de datos
digitales y convertirlos en un modelo
físico mediante una máquina que lo que
hará es depositar material una capa
sobre otra
la impresión 3d ha venido a modificar
como consumimos las cosas ha estado ha
calado en casi todos los nichos de
nuestra sociedad y específicamente en
medicina y el día de hoy
voy a hablar un poco de por qué pienso
que la impresión 3d es tan importante en
medicina hoy gracias a la impresión 3d
podemos ofrecerle a doctores y médicos
la posibilidad de tener en sus manos
modelos anatómicos que tienen una
altísima correlación con la anatomía del
paciente hoy les voy a hablar acerca de
planificación médica y de cómo la
impresión 3d mejora significativamente
la planificación la hace personal
pero como les dije tengo tres puntos por
los cuales yo pienso que la impresión 3d
es importante y es radical en medicina
el primero
gracias a la impresión 3d
la manufactura ahora es accesible
la manufactura por muchos años fue algo
reservado para grandes grupos económicos
para gente que tenía mucho dinero para
comprar grandes y costosas máquinas para
elaborar productos en altos volúmenes
gracias a la impresión 3d cualquiera de
nosotros tiene acceso a una máquina que
le va a permitir construir esos
productos
la manufactura ahora es accesible porque
cada uno de nosotros puede imprimir algo
puede crear algo y la impresora 3d no
necesita tener una esquila especial para
poderla manejar
primer punto
segundo punto
gracias a la impresión 3d la complejidad
es posible
y es que por el mismo hecho de que la
impresión 3d es aditiva que crea cosas
de manera aditiva añadiendo material es
que podemos crear formas de objetos muy
complejas
inclusive formas de objetos que no
pudieron ser creados de ninguna otra
manera con ningún otro proceso de
manufactura y es que
que hay más complejo que nuestro corazón
que hay más complejo que su pulmón
que su hígado que su riñón que su
cerebro
gracias a la impresión 3d si yo este
vídeo modelo lo corto por la mitad puedo
ver exactamente la estructura del
corazón la forma del corazón y eso no
pudo ser posible obtener de ninguna otra
manera que no sea mediante la impresión
3d
segundo punto
tercer punto
y yo creo que esta es la clave
fácilmente porque la impresión 3d
permite personalización porque hoy
gracias a la impresión 3d podemos
generar soluciones específicas
personalizadas y es que justamente de
eso se trata la medicina de generar
soluciones específicas para usted para
el problema que usted tiene para la
enfermedad que usted tiene planificar
una cirugía específicamente para usted
como este paciente que sufre de unmik
soma odonto génico lo que ustedes ven
hacia el lado derecho es un bio modelo
de su mandíbula y su maxilar superior y
pueden ver claramente esa protuberancia
es un tumor que el paciente tiene para
poder curarlo el doctor nos pidió éste
biomodelos para planificar la operación
como lo va a curar ahí es necesario
extraer esa porción de mandíbula que
está comprometida por el tumor y hay que
hacer un corte específico el doctor lo
tiene que planificar lo tiene que
ensayar luego de hacer ese corte va a
poner un implante proveniente de un
cadáver
pero gracias a la impresión 3d podemos
subirnos una máquina del tiempo y viajar
al futuro gracias a la impresión 3d
podemos entregarle al doctor elvio
modelo que ven al fondo eso es lo que
nos pidió el doctor cuando nos dijo
quiero saber cómo va a quedar mis
pacientes luego de la operación luego de
que yo ponga ese implante y gracias a la
impresión 3d lo pudimos hacer y usted se
preguntará y eso para qué me sirve bueno
luego colocar ese implante es necesario
colocar unas placas para fijar ese
implante y esas placas tienen que ser
dobladas conformadas con la misma forma
de la anatomía del paciente y ese es un
procedimiento exhaustivo que se realiza
dentro del quirófano que toma tiempo y
que obviamente más tiempo en el
quirófano significa más costo y más
riesgo de infección para el paciente
gracias a este modelo
el doctor pudo en la comodidad de su
oficina con toda la paciencia con todo
el tiempo del mundo
doblar esas placas antes de entrar en
quirófano y ahorrar muchísimo tiempo el
postoperatorio de esto tomo mucho menos
tiempo y elevamos la calidad de vida del
paciente
gracias a la impresión 3d podemos dar
soluciones como ésta lo que ustedes ven
a su lado izquierdo es una tomografía
del fémur de un paciente y lo que ven
más oscuro es un tumor que se llama
osteosarcoma hace 30 años la recepción
que se hacía era como la que ven en la
línea roja en donde básicamente el
paciente perdía su miembro o perdía su
articulación y usted se preguntará bueno
por qué no podemos hacer una recepción
como la amarilla que sería la más
elegante en donde solamente extraemos
esa porción del hueso comprometido el
problema es que cuando el doctor entra
quirófano expone al paciente el no puede
ver dónde está el tumor él no lo puede
ubicar él no sabe dónde está por eso
tiene que quedarse en márgenes de error
muy grandes porque si llegara a tocar
ese tumor durante la recepción éste se
va a expander iba a producir metástasis
gracias a la impresión 3d podemos
generar soluciones como la que ven en el
lado en su lado derecho como esta que
tengo en mis manos en donde pudimos
crear una guía de corte
exactamente la misma forma del paciente
personalizamos esta guía y el doctor va
a tener total confianza de que la puede
colocar sobre el paciente y va a encajar
perfecto y sobre esta guía colocamos un
patrón de corte de tal manera que el
doctor no tiene que seguir para extraer
únicamente la parte del hueso
comprometido
o como este paciente de aquí que tenía
un tumor en la parte posterior de su
tabique nasal que el doctor no lo podía
saber no lo podía ver claramente y no
podía cuantificar cuál era su tamaño y
gracias a la impresión 3d
pudimos imprimir exactamente la forma de
ese tumor para que el doctor pueda
planificar de una manera precisa cuál
era la recepción
ahora quiero volver a esta imagen quiero
volver a la historia temía decaiga de
dexter y de bentín porque en los cuatro
casos la impresión atrás dejó un papel
crucial y fundamental como el caso de
mía en el cual estuvo personalmente
involucrado porque el doctor en las
tomografías o en las imágenes médicas no
podía saber cuál era el defecto
estructural del corazón de mía y lo que
hicimos fue imprimir en 3-d una réplica
de su corazón lo pudimos recortar
diseccionar y el doctor puede entender
ahora sí claramente cuál era su problema
este vil modelo salvó la vida de mía
o como el caso de calva en donde siempre
habían estos implantes y estos sprints
que venían ya listos no venían con
ciertas medidas con ciertas tallas y
cada vez que se ponía uno de estos en
sprints la fallaba porque eran demasiado
grandes no eran del tamaño de la tráquea
mía y gracias a la impresión 3d pudimos
crear un implante un sprint el cual se
colocó exactamente de la medida de la
tráquea de cava
y cuando se colocó la tráquea de carga
se expandió y pudo volver a respirar
esté bien modelo salvó la vida de cava o
como dexter
cuyo único en donante de su hígado era
su papá y obviamente el hígado de dexter
era mucho más grande para entrar en
dexter que era muy pequeño gracias a
impresión 3d se pudo querer recrear la
caja toráxica de dexter y el doctor pudo
ensayar esta operación muy riesgosa dos
tres cinco o diez veces hasta poder
estar seguro de que lo iba a ser
correctamente
o como el caso de wikileaks en donde los
doctores tenían que realizar y ensayar
los cortes necesarios para expander el
cráneo bentley y poder introducir
nuevamente su cerebro dentro de él
estos bio modelo se usaron dentro del
quirófano porque claro cuanto venta
estaba siendo operada no podían hacer
una incisión muy grande no podían haber
hacer una abertura muy grande y el
doctor estaba operando a ciegas
entonces regresaban a los bio modelos
dentro del quirófano veía completo el
panorama de reptil y planificaban el
siguiente paso y regresaban otra vez
estos bien modelos salvaron la vida de
wenger
la impresión 3d está revolucionando la
medicina completamente
y hoy esa pregunta que usted siempre le
hace a su doctor cuando va a tener un
procedimiento quirúrgico va a cambiar
radicalmente su respuesta cada vez que
usted le pregunte a su doctor doctor
usted tiene experiencia en hacer este
pez esta operación
esta cirugía la ha hecho antes la
ensayado y riesgosa
hoy gracias a la impresión 3d el doctor
deba responder de una manera diferente
el doctor deba responder si no se
preocupe yo ya la ensayo y la ens ayer
usted
la hice en usted y la ensayo cinco diez
quince veinte veces y estoy
completamente seguro de que va a quedar
bien porque ya la ensayo en usted
hoy quiero que piense en la última vez
que fue a su doctor por alguna dolencia
probablemente se sentó el doctor le
preguntó cuáles son sus síntomas qué le
pasa y luego de eso el doctor lo tocó
el doctor lo palpó porque la medicina no
es un acto de fe es un acto de tocar
porque la cirugía no es un acto de
observar y de ver es un acto de tocar de
palpar de ensayar
hace 4 años cuando me vi involucrado
en un grupo en el cual salvamos a la
vida la primera es que salvamos la vida
de una persona utilizando impresión 3d
me di cuenta que esta era mi misión
esto es lo que yo tuve que hacer y yo me
tuve que adaptar porque era un ingeniero
mecánico que no sabía nada de medicina
y me tuve que adaptar porque estaba
convencido porque estoy convencido de
que esto es lo que quiero hacer por el
resto de mi vida
lo que yo quiero hacer por el resto de
mi vida es salvar vidas
utilizando impresión 3d
y por qué no en un futuro también
salvar
tu vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]